[Applaudissements]
le local c'est chez soi mais c'est où je
sois chez soi c'est sa maison c'est son
quartier c'est sa bile
mais ce soit c'est aussi cette montagne
cette mère cette plaine ou en ce sens le
seul habitant sur terre c'est ou chez
soi c'est soit c'est un espace et un
temps un espace celui où je me sens
moi-même celui où je peux enlever mes
masques et meetic est celui où je peux
me mettre à nu un espace et un temps le
temps de l'ordinaire le temps qui
structurent mon quotidien et le ton
aussi de l'extra ordinaire le temps de
l'unique et de l'exceptionnel chez soi
c'est un espace et un temps mais chez
soi c'est aussi des racines et des ailes
des racines mes racines mon histoire mon
passé mes origines mais blessures celles
qui ont cicatrisé et celles qui restent
toujours ouvertes
mes blessures et mes joies ses moments
éphémères qui m'ont marqué pour toujours
ce soit c'est des racines mais aussi des
ailes
c'est mon avenir c'est mon horizon c'est
ma boussole c'est ce qui me tire vers
l'avant c'est mes rêves c'est mes
illusions c'est mesut au pis c'est lier
qui me permets ici d'aller toujours plus
loin ce soit c'est des racines et des
ailes et c soit c'est aussi moi et les
autres
moi ma solitude
non pas celle que je subis mais celle
que je choisis ce monde d r non pas
celui où le chef mais celui où je
m'enfuis c'est ma tanière non pas celles
qui m'ont prison mais celle qui me rend
libre ce soit c'est moi et les autres
oui les autres ceux qui m'ont donné la
vie et surtout ceux qui m'ont donné
envie de vivre
mais ceci ceux qui m'en donner la mort
ce qui manque profondément blessé car
c'est grâce à eux qu'on apprend à
renaître le local c'est ce soit et ce
soit c'est un espace et un temps des
racines et des ailes
moi et les autres car le local
c'est-à-dire le chez soi se définit
moins par ce qui lui est propre que par
la relation qu'il a avec ce qui lui est
étranger le local c'est-à-dire le chez
soi c'est moins les murs de ma maison
que la manière dans ma maison me permet
d'habiter le monde
c'est une relation plutôt qu'au lieu
c'est une tension plus tôt que l'état
c'est un mouvement plutôt qu'une
appartenance le local ce n'est pas ce
qui reste
mais ce qui bouge le local ce n'est pas
ce qui se répète à l'identique mais ceux
qui se renouvellent en permanence le
local ce n'est pas ce qui est figé une
fois pour toutes
mais ce qui me permet d'être toujours au
mouvement
le local c'est le terreau qui me rend
créateur c'est le hummus qui me permet
de me développer c'est le compost qui me
fait naître et renaître en permanence or
le terreau le compost lemus sont
composés eux mêmes d'une multiplicité
d'être vivant des plantes des animaux
des bactéries qui se décompose et se
recompose qui se désagrège et se
rassemblent qui meurt et qui renaissent
et qui produit un flux de la vie et de
l'énergie vitale
le local c'est la terre mais non pas la
terre qui me fige
c'est la terre qui me rend vivant et
pour rendre vivant comme le terreau
comme le luz comme le compost
on a besoin de biodiversité
on a besoin du même et du différend on a
besoin d'ici et d'ailleurs
c'est pourquoi un territoire où il n'y a
que des autochtones
c'est un territoire qui risquent de
mourir de rigidité c'est pourquoi une
institution qui n'accepte pas la
différence
c'est une institution qui risquent de
s'engourdir
dans l'uniformité c'est pourquoi une
communauté qui se replie sur elle même
c'est une communauté qui risque
d'étouffer son chèque l'avez compris il
avait compris je crois à mieux que nous
tous en tout cas mieux que moi sur
chaque
c'est une de ces personnes qu'on appelle
handicapé mental et il vit dans l'une de
ces communautés qu'on appelle communauté
de l'arche
ce sont des communautés où cohabitent
des personnes avec handicap mental et
des personnes dites normales large
m'avait demandé d'aller rencontrer des
personnes de différentes communautés
pour leur parler du développement
durable vous savez ce développement qui
permet de faire durer la vie sur terre
je suis dans calais et ses commencer par
leur poser la question sur ce que
signifiait pour eux le terme
développement durable et ses chants
chaque qui m'a répondu le premier et il
m'a dit de ma communauté
avant on avait un seul poste de
télévision
maintenant on a acheté une télévision
pour chaque chambre développement pas
durable développement pas durable alors
j'essayais de comprendre ce que changea
que voulait me dire est ce lui poser la
question
ah oui ce que tu veux me dire c'est que
avant avec un seul poste de télévision
ont dépensé moins d'énergie que
maintenant avec plusieurs télévisions et
il me répond non non non non non avant
après le dîner on allait tous ensemble
regarder la télévision
maintenant après le dîner chacun va dans
sa chambre communauté pas
durable communauté pas durable jean
cheikh avait tout compris
il avait compris que ce qu'il y a à
faire durer sur terre c'est pas
tellement la matière mais l'énergie
vitale et que l'énergie vitale c'est de
l'énergie physique mais c'est surtout de
l'énergie relationnel sur chaque avait
compris que dans sa maison dans son chez
soi on a besoin des objets pour vivre
bien mais que la vocation ultime des
objets c'est pas tellement de satisfaire
des besoins mais c'est plutôt de renier
des personnes sur cheikh avait compris
que un local qui devient chez soi c'est
un lieu qui protège et qui expose c'est
un lieu qui place et qui déplace c'est
un lieu qui rassure et qui dérange
chaque avait compris que un local qui
rend vivant c'est un lieu où chacun se
construit non pas contre les autres mais
avec les autres dans une tension
permanente et féconde qui transforme le
chez soi on chez nous sa maison en
maison commune
voilà comment on chez interprète le
message que je crois que chaque voulais
me transmettre et que je partage
aujourd'hui avec vous que le local ce
n'est pas tellement un patrimoine à
sauvegarder mais c'est plutôt une terre
a habité est fécondé ensemble merci bon
[Applaudissements]